MCCARTHY AND ADMIRAL BRETT
GIROIR, AND DAN BROUILLETTE.
YOU MAY NOT HAVE LIVED DURING
THE WORLD WAR BUT YOU ARE LIVING
IN ONE NOW.
THIS WAR UNLIKE ANY WE HAVE
SEEN IN HISTORY.
AN INVISIBLE ENEMY CROSSING THE
WORLD WITH A VIRTUAL PAINT
BRUSH.
WE ARE HUNKERED DOWN, SHELTERED
IN PLACE.
AND PRAYING FOR LIFE AT THE END
OF THE TUNNEL.
300,000 AMERICANS STRICKEN.
8,000 KILLED.
THE LEADER OF THE GREATEST
NATION ON EARTH IS IN A WAR
POSTURE.
WE WATCH PRESIDENT TRUMP DAILY
AS HE TRIES TO TAKE THIS COUNTRY
FROM A PLACE OF FRIGHTENING
REALITY TO A POSITION OF
STRENGTH.
AT THE SAME TIME AS A
BUSINESSMAN HE’S MINDFUL OF THE
FREE ENTERPRISE SYSTEM THAT
PRODUCED THE VAST WEALTH THAT
FUNDS THE VITAL INSTITUTIONS
THAT PROTECT US, INCLUDING OUR
MEDICAL SYSTEM.
FINDING SOLUTIONS TO WIN THIS
WAR.
BEGINNING IN JANUARY BLOCK THOSE
COMING FROM JANUARY NEARLY 10
DAYS AFTER THE FIRST CORONAVIRUS
CASE WAS IDENTIFIED IN THE
UNITED STATES.
HE BROUGHT TOGETHER THE MOST
BRILLIANT MINDS IN SCIENCE AND
MEDICINE, HEALTHCARE, ENERGY,
AND MANUFACTURING TO FIGHT THIS
I VISIBLE ENEMY.
AND HE BRINGS THEM OUT TO BE
QUESTIONED AND CROSS-EXAMINED.
HE FEARS NO ONE, AND IS NOT
AFRAID OF COMPLETE TRANSPARENCY.
HE TRIGGERED THE DEFENSE
PRODUCTION ACT TO BEGIN MASS
PRODUCTION OF NEEDED SUPPLIES.
HE EVEN GAINED IN THE PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP GIVING
CREDIT TO COMPANIES LIKE WALMART
AND TARGET AND BOEING AND MORE.
COMPANIES WHO STEPPED UP,
COMPANIES THAT ASKED FOR NOTHING
AND OFFERED HELP IN SPITE OF THE
FACT THEY ARE SUFFERING THEIR
OWN FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS.
AND HE CALLED OUT 3M AND GM FOR
NOT DOING ENOUGH TO FIGHT THE
VIRUS.
THE NAVY SHIP, THE WHOSESHIP
COMFORT *OOO -- THE HOSPITALSHIP
IS IN THE NEW YORK HARBOR AND
ITS SISTER SHIPS MERCY IS ON THE
WEST COAST.
IN TYPICAL TRUMP FASHION HE
DELIVERED AHEAD OF SCHEDULE.
THANK GOD AT THIS MOMENT IN
AMERICA’S HISTORY WE HAVE A
BUSINESSMAN AS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AS LEADER, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOESN’T LISTEN THE TO THE
LIEUTENANTS MOANING AND WHINING
AND MAKING OUTRAGEOUS CLAIMS AS
THEY SIT AND PONTIFICATE ABOUT
WHAT SHOULD BE DONE FOR THEM.
ABOUT WHAT THEY NEED WHICH IN
SOME CASES THEY ALREADY HAVE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MORE THAN
CAPABLE AND WOULD BE JUSTIFIED
TO COUNTER PUNCH BASED ON THE
RIDICULOUS CLAIMS HE COULD
EASILY REBUTT.
>> AS THE PRESIDENT FIDDLES,
PEOPLE ARE DYING.
JUDGE JEANINE: THE ONLY
PERSON FIDDLING IS YOU.
THE PRESIDENT IS IN FULL
THROTTLE WAR TIME MODE AS A
GENERAL, FOCUSED ON KEEPING ALL
OF US SAFE AND HEALTHY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS TALKED ABOUT
MAYOR DEBLASIO.
HE’S BEING COMPLIMENTED BY
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM.
HE EBB COMPLIMENTED DEMOCRATS ON
THE STIMULUS BILL, CHOOSING NOT
TO COMMENT ON THE EFFORT TO
INCLUDE THE GREEN NEW DEAL,
ABORTION FUNDING AND MILLIONS
FOR THE KENNEDY CENTER.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN BEYOND
GRACIOUS EVEN TO CHINESE
PRESIDENT XI JINPING.
HE BELIEVES THE VIRUS STEMS FROM
THE WET MARKET IN WUHAN, CHINA
WHERE ANIMALS LIE NEXT TO EACH
OTHER IN OPEN MARKETS.
A VIRTUAL PETRI DISH WHERE VIRUS
CAN JUMP FROM ANIMALS TO HUMANS.
EVEN DR. ANTHONY FAUCI AS TO
WHETHER WET MARKETS SHOULD EXIST
SAID THIS.
>> I THINK THEY SHOULD SHUT THAT
DOWN RIGHT AWAY.
IT BOGGLES MY MIND WHEN WE HAVE
SO MANY DISEASES THAT HE NATE
OUT OF THAT UNUSUAL HUMAN-ANIMAL
INTERFACE THAT WE DON’T JUST
SHUT IT DOWN.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT ELSE HAS TO
HAPPEN.
JUDGE JEANINE: CHINA HAS TO BE
MADE ACCOUNTABLE FOR ITS
COMPLETE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY.
CHINA COULD HAVE PREVENTED A
GREAT DEAL OF PAIN AND LOSS,
BOTH PHYSICAL AND ECONOMIC IF
THEY HAVE BEEN HONEST.
WE HAVE A LOT OF TIME TO THINK
ABOUT HOW THIS NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED AS IT RELATES TO CHINA